what's that bleep nation at seven I'm
about to hit two pretty big milestones
and I could really use your help your
love and your support
number one I'm about to hit 1 million
subscribers whoo probably Monday
probably Tuesday one of those two days
I'm looking at doing a live stream and
still have not figured out what I'm
gonna do what I'm gonna give away how
it's gonna run so this is your last
chance you have ideas for what I should
do on my 1 million subscriber livestream
to celebrate with you guys leave in the
comments let me know hopefully doesn't
happen to some crazy time at you know 3
in the morning my time for something but
Monday Tuesday I'm looking good from a
calendar perspective I'm Ernie warning
the people that I'm supposed to be
meeting with that it may not be
happening because I gotta be with you
guys live so that's very exciting coming
up on Monday Tuesday again give me your
ideas what should be doing in the live
stream giving away stuff I don't know I
don't know let me know I need your input
I want to make it a fun one really to
celebrate you guys in the journey that
we've been out together
and number two is the book comes out
December 6 that'll be the following week
on the Wednesday that one is a more
definite timeline and now that I want to
do around there again I'm not so worried
about the launches you know for me it's
a it's the process it's the ongoing it's
like getting the book out to everybody
all the time not just on launch day but
I don't know maybe we should do a live
stream on launch day maybe shoot
something else I'm a huge fan of let me
show you I gotta here let me show you
let me pull it up let me pull it up
right look at that ah that's a sexy book
I read this every morning one page a day
makes a huge difference and I can't wait
to get it into your hands so any ideas
suggestions recommendations if you think
either livestream other ideas you might
have hit me up in the comments thank you
for your love appreciation loyalty
feedback I can't wait to see what you
have to say on my two big milestones
give me your ideas hit me up really
appreciate it
thank you guys again I will see you next
week
on the livestream and maybe the week
after too much love guys continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
give me the one wooden box once long you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details